buonasera a tutti due volte e un
riferimento hub e rischi imprenditoriali
che io intrapreso nella mia vita non per
una mia propensione al rischio ma solo
per un certo coraggio e determinazione a
concretizzare le de in cui credo le
volte dunque anche un racconto il
racconto di due storie per così dire di
coraggio imprenditoriale
la prima conclusasi la seconda non
ancora conclusa sì che io vi racconterò
inserendole in una sintesi nella mia
esperienza di vita lavorativa
io sono nato a lecce o una licenza
biologica l'università di perugia una
specializzazione in genetica medica a
roma e ho lavorato in genetica per i
miei primi cinque anni nella vita post
laurea e questo è il primo dei sei
periodi della mia vita
dopodichè sono entrato nell'industria
farmaceutica lepetit leader degli
antibiotici in italia come ricercatore
presso il il l'impianto di produzione di
brindisi e questo è il secondo periodo
per passare poi al centro di ricerche
della stessa società a gerenzano in
provincia di varese come direttore del
dipartimento di scienze biologiche qui
inizia il terzo periodo terzo periodo
molto importante per me per la mia
famiglia per due motivi primo
trasferimento da lecce a como doveri
sediamo tuttora secondo motivo per un
fatto molto importante che accade pochi
mesi dopo il mio trasferimento cosa
accade accade che la casa madre della
gruppo les petits fu acquisita e al
termine di un lungo processo per
definire il ridimensionamento della
società venne comunicato che il centro
di ricerche di gerenzano che era noto in
tutto il mondo per la qualità della sua
produzione scientifica non era più
strategico per la nuova società è
risultato doveva essere chiuso demolito
il terreno bonificate posti in vendita
tutto entro il 31 12 del 1996
voi potete immaginare lo shock al a
quella comunicazione restiamo sbigottiti
senza parole vi fu un gelo nell'aula una
situazione di buio perché avevamo
perduto tutti i punti di riferimento si
leva una voce poi un'altra e montona
protesta una protesta forte una protesta
dura ma ancora composta perché vi era la
possibilità di vendere il centro ma
quando nell'aprile del 96
tale possibilità svenire il tutto allora
la reazione cus composta il livello di
entropia nel centro aumento fino al
massimo livello
50 dei ricercatori stranieri andarono
via de circa 120 rimasti la maggior
parte si rifiutava di lavorare
incrociando le braccia io hp in quel
momento che non poteva assistere inerte
alla scomparsa di un centro di ricerche
di così grande valore
dovevo fare qualcosa e allora mi misi a
lavorare su un progetto di conversione
di un centro di ricerche nella società
di biotecnologia farmaceutica il
progetto sembrava molto difficile ma io
generai dei numeri con il mio business
plan che mi diedero il coraggio a
continuare presenta il progetto vertici
della società cui autorizzato ad andare
avanti e poi nominato direttore del
centro di ricerche per meglio operare
bene iniziai dunque una corsa perché
bisognava far presto bisognava finire
tutto entro il 31 12 del 96 questa corsa
fu una corsa ad ostacoli ostacoli
imprevedibili sui quali sorvolo e arrivò
direttamente all'ultimo giorno
nel 1996 quando nasce la società
biosearch italia è così inizio quarto
periodo biosearch italia che viene
salutata dalla stampa con grande
interesse aveva un obiettivo ben preciso
una mission ben precisa quella di
fornire medici nuovi antibiotici per il
trattamento di infezioni gravi
ospedaliere spesso mortali e lo scopo
era quello non solo di scoprire ma anche
di sviluppare produrre e
commercializzare questi farmaci
salvavita ma per far questo era vissuto
di una montagna di denaro e dunque il
nocciolo vero della questione era dove
prendere tutto questo denaro
la mia idea era quella di prenderlo in
borsa ma non vi erano società di
biotecnologie quotate in borsa al tempo
neviera un idonea mercato borsistico su
cui quotare questo tipo di società
dunque la mission sembrava veramente
impossibile però per fare una lunga
storia breve arriviamo al luglio del
2000 e la società si quota in borsa con
grande attenzione della stampa grande
entusiasmi piazza affari dove il titolo
si quota a 42 euro e 50 che era il
massimo dell'offerta pubblica per
chiudere la se la seduta 50 euro e
schizzare a 78 euro nei due mesi
successivi essere in borsa in quel
periodo nella new economy in particolare
era come essere sulle montagne russe
sulle montagne russe se prima si sale e
noi saremo fino a duplicare quasi il
valore iniziale poi si scende noi
scendemmo fragorosamente
bruciando circa il 90 per cento del
valore di capitalizzazione della società
dopo l'undici settembre il valore era
solo 8 euro
cosa fare bisognava uscire da quella
situazione ma bisognava uscire una
maniera decisa forte e io lo feci
facendo una flessione con un partner
americano creando versi col creando
vecchio non pharmaceuticals fu quotata
al nuovo mercato e anche al nasdaq
avevamo creato un business
transatlantico e così salvato il titolo
che riprese la sua ripresa a crescere
dopo l'annuncio come vedete
agganciandosi al titolo americano
sganciandosi definitivamente dal trend
del nuovo mercato che continua nella sua
discesa inarrestabile bene ero molto
soddisfatto abbiamo salvato una società
i suoi valori e così negli stati uniti
dove io mi trasferì nel con la mia
famiglia finisce la prima storia per
nascerne un'altra io potrei condividere
la mia straordinaria passione per il
vino con tanti amici americani e allora
compresi come loro che erano stanchi dei
vini omologati avrebbero potuto
apprezzare i vini italiani così diverse
e poco conosciuti e quindi questa poteva
essere un'opportunità per l'italia è
così in un misto tra spirito patriottico
e stanchezza di avere il rumore legato
al al titolo in borsa
io ho deciso di tornare in italia con la
mia famiglia ho creato una società
io ho investito nel vino seguendo la mia
passione in realtà ho fatto altri
investimenti tutti legati allo sviluppo
territoriale e ho fatto un grosso errore
l'errore è stato quello di credere di
poter controllare tutti questi
investimenti dal mio ufficio di coma
vendone affidato la gestione a persone
che ritenevo affidabili questo non è
stato queste persone non sono rivelate
tali
io ho subito fortissime perdite
economiche che mi hanno costretto a
chiudere tutti gli investimenti ma non
quello sul vino anzi questo lo
incrementato per migliorare le aziende
per migliorare tenute mera questa
azienda pugliese nei vigneti nella
cantina i suoi vitigni autoctoni come di
aggravare il primitivo questo brand che
si chiama sud del sud che raffigura la
scultura che con l'artista e amico
ercole pignatelli abbiamo donato a lecce
la scultura rappresenta l'unione delle
culture nell'uomo il vino vuole
rappresentare
le culture viticole dove negramaro e
primitivo incontrano i vitigni
internazionali
e poi ancora la nella cantina la cantina
di san paolo che in campania è ancora
nelle attrezzature di cantina nei
vigneti nei suoi vini falanghina greca
piano mitici vini bianchi della campania
e ancora i cru oggetto di ricerca del
territorio e nella bella sede di
guardiano ma tutti questi investimenti
ad aver cambiato il management non ha
cambiato le cose l'azienda continuato a
perdere e questo è stato il periodo più
brutto della mia vita veramente in
questo periodo ogni giorno venivo come
dire dilaniato quasi dal dubbio se
bloccare tutto disinvestire quindi
salvare il salvabile oppure proseguire
però con il rischio di perdere tutto e
io ho deciso di andare avanti supportato
e incoraggiato dalla scelta di mia
figlia che ha deciso dopo nell'area la
bocconi di venire ad aiutarmi in azienda
e così nasce il mio sesto periodo che il
periodo dell'emigrante al contrario
quindi dal luglio del 2012
io ho aumentato le mie frequenze in
azienda che sono diventate sempre
presidio continuate a investire adesso
non finite da investire
dunque investo me stesso e finalmente mi
sono spogliato di questi ambiti
l'imprenditore biofarmaceutico per
vestire questi abiti di vignaiolo e così
insieme con via figli abbiamo portati
l'azienda persone leali e valide e con
queste persone con mio nipote ancora in
azienda con tanti altri collaboratori
bravi e fedeli stiamo riorganizzando
l'azienda messa sulla giusta strada dopo
tanti anni finalmente io riesco a vedere
la luce
ecco io vorrei ringraziare esso mia
moglie antonella che per la pazienza il
coraggio il mio figlio di rendere anche
bene
grazie a mio figlio per andrea che
lavora e vive a ginevra per per crederci
sempre e ovviamente mia figlia
alessandra
io spero che questo brindisi per la
avvenuta raccolta dell'uva possa essere
un brindisi propiziatorio per
raccogliere finalmente il successo dopo
tanti anni di duro lavoro grazie per
l'attenzione